wollen wir müssen offen hannover ist
luca herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen
video sind lange blendet ich hasse das
ei phone 7 ist die komplette wahrheit
habe ich jetzt jedoch erstmal wie das
ganze zustande kam ich habe mich vor
einer woche mit meinem vater dabei
unterhalten die dann wohl das neue
iphone aussehen wird und man sind
vorbestellt worden wie komisch ist
deutsch
er meinte dann zu mir er war schon eine
telekom laden und hat sich schon das
neue album 7 vor reservieren lassen das
war irgendwie möglich ich hatte auch
keine ahnung dass es funktioniert aber
er hat auf jeden fall getan und ich
meine das team
ich möchte auch das neue iphone ich bin
einfach ein apple fan ich muss das so
sagen haltet mich ruhig aber ich habe
auch eine apple logic arbeitet mit
meinem macbook pro schneide damit die
videos zu hause habe ich in haiming
stehen um eine videos aufzunehmen wenn
ich am computer sitzt was zocke ich mag
es einfach dass alles miteinander
verbunden ist und alles von der gleichen
marke ist ich mag apple hängt mich wo
ich am galgen oder macht sonst was mit
mir wir haben dann auf jeden fall bei
der telekom angerufen ich habe mir das
iphone sieben wochen ihren lassen also
dass wenn sie rauskommen dass ich dann
halt eine bevorzugte personen mit und
dann sagen darüber informiert habe dann
halt im internet gesehen ok siebte
september abends pressekonferenz als
deutscher zeit abends ich glaube in
amerika wasser gerade zehn uhr morgens
19 uhr sollte der livestream stattfinden
das war gestern ist ca genau 24 stunden
her und ich habe mich dann halt mit
meinem essen abends von den laptop
gesetzt jedoch die apple website
gegangen und habe mir diese live
angeschaut typisch apple ja erstmal zehn
jahre über updates und wie toll sie sind
und was sie alles verkauft haben hat
mich auf jeden fall alles nicht gejuckt
dann wird halt die apple watch 272
irgendwie so vorgestellt
ich bin mit der normalen apple watch die
ich derzeit habe komplett unzufrieden
deswegen interessiert mich die zweite
auch nicht und dann wirklich nach
gefühlten stunden ich glaube es waren
sogar zwei stunden bis dahin vergangen
waren wurde das
iphone 7 vorgestellt und ich habe mich
wirklich darauf gefreut so jo es gab es
iphone 6 und 6 1 hatte genau das gleiche
design hatten es hinten dran stehen mich
gefreut neues design was richtig
innovatives vielleicht etwas richtig
cooles vielleicht irgendwie so ein
bisschen geboten sondern bildschirm der
irgendwann ganz dingen und was es zählt
einfach genauso aus wie sollte er jetzt
man vergleich freunde das hier ist mein
iphone 6 s und jetzt werde ich euch mal
rechts das neue iphone ein exakt das
gleiche eigentlich wollte mich
verarschen hätte ich habe mich echt auf
neues design gefreut ich sagte okay 17
muss was neues kommen ja das packt mich
als erstes ab da habe ich mal die
keynote weiter angeschaut und war dann
habt wirklich was sollten hab mich
gefreut und hätte ich hab das einfach 7
vorbestellte seines mit zwar wirklich in
dem moment wirklich krass egal gewesen
aber was ich halte dich die haben schon
coole sachen vorgestellt beispielsweise
gesagt dass der ton jetzt hier und hier
rauskommen dass hier unten halt dieser
schlag für die i pods nicht mehr da ist
sondern da auch lautsprecher hinkommen
und die airports war sie beim kabel in
den leitungen adapter reingehen damit
wären erst mal gedacht ok typisch apple
was ist mit meinen alten kopfhörer muss
ich noch mal verkaufen sie gesagt sie
legen den adapter bei dass ein lightning
auf klinker adapter mit dabei liegt
insofern nicht als ultra coolen vettel
hat nicht da irgendwie wieder so ein
bisschen von sich überzeugt dann haben
sie halt gesagt es gibt ein von 7 und 7
class also genauso wie beim 6er groß
normale sechs ergibt und 6 plus was halt
ein bisschen größer ist und sorry an
alle käufer von dem iphone 6 aber ich
sehe es nicht ein dass das ist für mich
ihn heißt also ich finde handy muss
klein sein und selbst das hier passten
nicht mal richtig ganz in meiner hand
rein so das ist mir auch schon ein
bisschen zu groß ich meine haye
leute das plus modell feiern sollen sie
es gerne tun für mich war es auf jeden
fall von anfang an klar okay wenn ich
mir das iphone 7 hole dann auf jeden
fall das kleine und dann wurden was
vorgestellt was mich ein bisschen
abgefuckt hat ein bisschen sehr
abgefuckt hat die kamera for my phone 7
ist ansich supercoole abwägen was gesagt
so ja voll viele kameras übereinander
und vorlauf mit neuen blitz und image
travel agent es wieder besser geworden
mehr farben bla bla bla bla bla es immer
das gleiche und dann wurde was in das
was ich mir schon so lange gewünscht hat
nämlich dieser boke filter so dass man
quasi sieht sie jetzt gerade eine kamera
ein bisschen mein gesicht des komplett
charme und der hintergrundes umschauen
wenn ich dir draufdrücken ist der
hintergrund schafe mein gesicht und
schafft das ist dieses unschärfe tiefen
regelung things genauso heiß und
schärfentiefe regenschirms dings das hat
mich beim iphone fotos immer so
abgefuckt dass wenn ich irgendwie mich
selbst fotografiere und ein foto von mir
macht mir dass ich halt komplett
schaffte nur bei der hintergrund auch
und ich lese sie sollten sich eine ebene
mit dem hintergrund läuten wir sind
nicht so oft fotos machen können das
nicht nachvollziehen aber ich finds ein
cooler wenn einfach dieses hier ich bin
ihr fokus und da hintergrundes überhaupt
nicht zu erkennen die haben das
vorgestellt und ich sag's damit nach
freund hat mir nur so gedacht war wie
geil dass das kommt einer da freue ich
mich recht trocken nur iphone 7 + ich
zeige euch mal wie es dann außer wollen
wir besprachen sie genauso
mich hat das so abgefuckt wir kennen das
ja bestimmt
der mensch hat erwartungen seien
erwartungen liegenden partyabend
erwartungen
ein neues pass liga dass ich verkaufe
oder erwartungen an ein neues iphone
vorgestellt wir uns von den fünf
erwartungen wie ich an jedes ei phone 7
hatte wurde nur eine teils erfüllt das
ist so traurig diese fünf erwartungen
die ich hatte waren erstens dass das
display quasi über die komplette
vorderseite geht und der home-button
irgendwie integriert ist dass ich eine
unschärfe filterung scheiße auch wenn im
normalen 7 bekomme dass ich ein neues
design bekommen als das hier um dich so
ein halbes iphone 6 es 2.0 was jetzt
vorgestellt wurde dass die batterie
mindestens doppelt so großes und die
batterie wurde vielleicht um einen
stunde erweitert oder so und das ist
wasser resistent ist und das muss ich
sagen haben sie teils hingekriegt aber
auch nur gegen spritzwasser oder
irgendwie so will ja nicht mal wieder
davon überzeugen dass sich das neue
gerät überhaupt nicht cool finde ich
wäre es natürlich trotzdem kaufen weil
man immer das neueste haben wenn du dich
apple merkt aber ich bin enttäuscht ich
meiner werden sie so an als würde ich
das iphone komplett vorhaben scheuen mit
ich hasse es zwar aber ich finde im park
machen sind echt cool geworden also das
design ist jetzt nicht ultra bescheuert
es ist sieht halt genauso in 60 mit
geringfügigen änderungen aber ich finds
neid vor allem die zwei neuen farben
eingeführt haben also es gibt es einmal
in roségold gold dann in diesem silber
weiß wo ich auf das 16 11h oder hat noch
zwei neue farben und zwar immer die
ammann schwarz und sohn max schwarz das
ist dieses mattschwarz das ist die ultra
froschhausen das hier ist ihr mann
schwarz und das wollte ich halt wirklich
eigentlich haben ich finde das
eigentlich das matte cooler aber diese
matten luca nicht mir auch gegen die mit
nach halle holen und dieses grenzen auf
der rückseite wenn ich einfach ultra
coolen das heißt ja man schwarz wird
sich einfach geil an will habe ich
allerdings gesehen ok hinter jack
blecker steht eine kleine zwei hinter
was könnte denn das bedeuten dass
glänzende finish des iphone sieht man
schwarz ist das resultat eines prozesses
bei dem neuen stufen
auch jessica und jetzt haltet euch fest
dennoch können mit der zeit winzige
abnutzungserscheinungen sichtbar werden
um dem vorzubeugen empfehlen wir eines
der vielen verfügbaren cases zu
verwenden mit denen das iphone geschützt
werden kann
ihr bringenden design raus ich kriege
ich die krise endlich auf dieses iphone
gefreut und ich wurde in so krasser
hinsicht nur enttäuscht ich werde es mir
trotzdem holen freunde ich denke schon
aber ich find's einfach nur lächerlich
dies komplett hinter meinen erwartungen
ich kann nicht mal mehr sätze wenn ich
heute gerade innerlich und bereue ist
dass sich bei der telekom gesagt habe
okay ich möchte sonnigen vor dem
servieren lassen angeblich kann man das
handy morgan freeman ich weiß nicht wie
das jetzt genau bei mir abläuft und ob
ich das wirklich machen werde oder nicht
wollte ich einfach meine meinung dazu
sagen und dies schlimm
also schreibt mir mal unten in die
kommentare
bitte was ihr euch gewünscht hätte oder
ob ihr zufrieden seid mit dem neuen
iphone dass ihr mit dem video meine
damen und herren ich hoffe es hat euch
irgendwie gefallen hat es getan hat
freue ich mich über eine bewertung ich
habe mich einfach dazu gefühl meine
gedanken über das neue iphone mit
jemandem zu teilen und dafür ist youtube
da deswegen auch jj barea
wir warten jetzt meinen kleinen test und
zwar kommentiert man mit dem wort v7
wenn die apple feiert und das iphone 7
gerne haben wollen würde das bestellt
hat mich davon überzeugt seid oder
kommentiert mit scheiden apple wenn die
apple hass und nicht zufrieden sein
würde mich mal interessieren wie viele
kommentare zu welcher partei kommen
außerdem könnt ihr hier oben einen kanal
abonnieren und hier findet ihr musical
video verlinkt also
klick und bis jetzt kommen alle von
zecken oder scheiß apple zu welcher
meinung sein
das war vom video ich bin raus aber
leben ist kurz